sir
look at the captain leo
you must have really messed up if they
sent you to leo
do you know why you're here because i
broke chain of command
harp he's not like us
you're up your commanding officer let me
give you 60 seconds to deal with it
yes sir
cool
what are you ai i'm gump say i i'm a
prototype and my existence is classified
but i can't do this alone i need someone
who could think outside the box
that's why you're here i chose you you
got a picture of her
i'm not even having this confidence hey
it's fair game rookie
she's a hottie congratulations thank you
hey my gummy bear
oh my gummy bear
please tell me what you know in front of
him you can trust him
these are your informants listen i'm a
combat soldier but i feel more than you
think
i can't do this with eyes on me they put
your tracker in your back sometimes you
got to get dirty to see any real change
welcome to the war kid for myself
i need you to trust me harp
what would you do with so much power
we can be good allies in extreme
situations i have the ability to break
the rules
just like you that was going on art
i removed this fell safe you did what
your war machine turns against you why
should i care
how long do you think you'll survive out
here on your own
what are you using me for
do you trust me
[Music]
you